البحريه الامريكيه تكشف عن مصادره شحنه
اسلحه ايرانيه غير شرعيه في الثالث
والعشرين من فبراير الماضيه
ذخائر امريكيه لتايوان بقيمه 619 مليون
دولار لتعزيز قدراتها الدفاعيه
يحمل طاقم محطه فضاء من ولايه فلوريدا
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير واهلا بكم الى هذه النشره
الاخباريه من العربيه كشفت البحريه
الامريكيه عن مصادره شحنه اسلحه ايرانيه
غير شرعيه في 23 من فبراير الماضي
بالتعاون مع البحريه البريطانيه في خليجي
عمان مؤكده على ان القارب الايراني
المصادر كان يحمل على متنه صواريخ
باليستيه وصواريخ موجهه مضاده للدبابات
تشبه صواريخ كورنات الروسيه ونقل البيان
عن براد كوبر قائد القياده المركزيه
للقوات البحريه الامريكيه والاسطول الخامس
ان هذه السابع عمليه مصادره لاسلحه او
مخدرات في الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه ومثال
اخر على النشاط الايراني البحري الضار
الاخذ في التزايد في المنطقه
من جانب اخر افادت وكاله تسنيم ان السفن
الحربيه التابعه للاسطول السادس والثمانين
في البحريه الايرانيه مرت عبر قناه بنما
ورصت في ميناء ريودي جينيرو في اول رحله
حول العالم في تاريخ الاسطول الايراني
واكدت الوكاله الايرانيه انه من بين هذه
السفن توجد حامله المروحيات مكرام
والمدمره دانا
واجرى الجيش الايراني والحرس الثوري
تدريبات دفاعيه مشتركه لمحاكاه هجوم على
المواقع النوويه والعسكريه وقال ان
التدريبات تغطت ثلثي المجال الجوي للبلاد
[موسيقى]
وفيما يتعلق ببرنامج ايران النووي قال
رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي مايك ماكول قال ان طهران تختبروا
عزيمه المجتمع الدولي فيما يتعلق
ببرنامجها النووي وحثم قول اداره بايدن
على احاله ايران الى مجلس الامن في
الاجتماع المقبل لمجلس محافظي الوكاله
الذريه وطالب مكون الاداره الامريكيه
بالسعي الى التوصل الى نتيجه رسميه بشان
عدم امثال ايران نوويا وان تظهر الولايات
المتحده ردا يظهر التزامها الصارم بمنعها
من الحصول على سلاح نووي رئيس لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه في مجلس النواب الامريكي دعا الى
اخضاع ايران للمساءله عن عنادها المستمر
حفاظا على نزاهه وكاله الطاقه الذريه
كمنظمه دوليه مايكل ماكول اكد ايضا ان
ايران خصبت اليورانيوم لدرجه
83.7% وهي قريبه بشكل مقلق من درجات
التسليح
ايراني اخر حتى الخارجيه الامريكيه ايران
على التحقيق فيها هجمات تسميم طالبات وهي
ظاهره يتخوف الايرانيون من اتساعها بعد
مضي ثلاثه اشهر على رصد اول حاله تسمم
فيما ترفض الاجهزه المسؤوله تحديد الاسباب
او نوعيه المواد التي تتسبب بحالات
الاختناق بالمدارس
المشهد لم يختلف كثيرا عن الاحتجاجات التي
اندلعت اثرى مقتل مسا امين في ايران
فسيارات الاسعاف لم تعد تنقل جرح الاصابات
الداميه وانما فتيات يبكين توعكا فجائيا
اصابهن او يعانين من ضعف العضلات والخمول
والغثيان لساعات او يعانين من حالات
اختناق وفي احدث موجه تسمم تعرضت طالبه من
سبع مدارس في مدينه اردبيل ومن ثلاث مدارس
اخرى في العاصمه الى تسمم نوع من الرذاذ
يتكون من غاز النيتروجين الذي يستخدم في
الصناعه او كسماد زراعي ونشرت مقاطع عده
لاحتجاجات اولياء الطالبات المصابات
وقالوا ان المدرسه تتصل بنا وتطلب ان ناخذ
بناتنا دون ان تعطينا معلومات اخرى
وفي هذه الموجه الاخيره من مسلسل الارهاب
البيولوجي ينتظر الاهالي كلمه تفسر ما
الذي يجري حينما يرسلون في الذات اكبادهم
الى المدارس فتاره يقر مسؤولون في وزاره
الصحه بحدوث حالات تسمم لكنهم يصرون على
انها ليست بموده كيميائيه بينما يؤكد
مسؤول اخر من ذات الجهه انه ليس فيروسا
لينتهي بالقول ان الاعداء وحدهم من يقفون
وراء كل تلك المصائب التي حلت على البلاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صدقه الولايات المتحده على بيع تايوان
ذخائر بقيمه 619 مليون دولار لطائراتها
المقاتله من طراز اف 16 وتضم هذه الصفقه
التي يتوقع ان تثير استياء بكين 100 صاروخ
عالي السرعه مضاد للرادارات و200 صاروخ جو
جو متوسط المدى وقاذفه صواريخ واكدت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه ان هذه الصفقه ستعزز
قدره التايوان على ضمان الدفاع عن مجالها
الجوي والامن الاقليمي والتوافق في
العمليات مع الولايات المتحده
اكد وزير الخارجيه الهندي وجود خلافات
حاده في الراي داخل مجموعه العشرين بشان
النزاعات الدوليه والازمات العالميه وقال
خلال افتتاح اجتماع وزراء خارجيه مجموعه
العشرين ان العالم ينتظر ايجاد ارضيه
مشتركه لحل النزاعات ومواجهه ازمات المناخ
وهشاشه سلاسل التوريد والديونه
قبل ذلك اعتبر رئيس الوزراء الهندي نارين
درامودي ان المؤسسات المتعدده الاطراف
فشلت في مواجهه التحديات الاكثر الحاحا في
العالم وخلال خطابه في افتتاح اجتماع
لوزراء خارجيه دول مجموعه العشرين في
نيودلهي قلم دين تجربه السنوات القليله
الماضيه فيما يخص الازمه الماليه والتغير
المناخي والجائحه والارهاب والحروب تظهر
بوضوح ان الحوكمه العالميه قد فشلت وشدد
على انه يجب عدم السماح للقضايا التي لا
يمكنهم حلها معا ان تعيق تلك القضايا التي
يمكنهم الاجماع على احلها
علن وزير الدفاع السعودي الامير خالد بن
سلمان انه وقع مع نظيره البريطاني بنوالص
اعلان نوايا بشان مشاركه المملكه في
برنامج القدرات الجويه المستقبليه واضاف
الامير خالد عبر حسابه على تويتر ان
البرنامج سيسهم في تعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه
للمملكه وتطوير المنظومات الجويه
المستقبليه واشار وزير الدفاع السعودي الى
انه بحث مع نظيره البريطاني التعاون في
المجال العسكري والدفاعي وسبل تعزيز
نشرتنا مسمر مستمر وفيها بعض الفاصل
واعشوا تدرس ما حلفائها فرض عقوبات على
الصين اذا ثبت دعمها
اهلا بكم من جديد افاده مصادر مطلعه في
الولايات المتحده بان اربعه مسؤولين
امريكيين اكدوا ان اداره الرئيس جو بايدن
تتواصل مع حلفائها المقربين بشان احتمال
فرد عقوبات اقتصاديه جديده على الصين وفق
المصادر فان التجهيز لفرض العقوبات شمل
اتصالات غير رسميه على مستوى الموظفين
والدبلوماسيين سيتم فرضها فور اكتشاف ان
الصين ارسلت بالفعل مساعدات عسكريه لروسيا
لدعمها في حربها مع اوكرانيا خاصه وان واش
صرحت عده مرات انبيكين تعتزم تزويد روسيا
بالاسلحه
قال الرئيس الاوكراني فولوديلينسكي في
كلمه عبر الاتصال المرئي ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تسيطر على كل قطعه الجبهه جاءت
كلمه زيلينسكي بعد ساعه فقط من اعلان
القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه تتقدم بالقرب من مدينه باخمه
الرئيسيه في شرق البلاد بدوره قلم مؤسس
فاجنر الروسيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه تدافع
عن مدينه بخموت بكامل قواها مؤكدا ان بحرا
من الدماء يسيل هناك على حد وصفه
افادت مجله الفكره العسكري التابعه لوزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان موسكو تعمل على تطبيق
استراتيجيه وتطويرها عسكريا من نوع جديد
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه لمواجهه عدوان
امريكي محتمل الى ان موسكو ستكون مستعده
اذا لزم الامر لنشر ترسانتها النوويه
الضخمه كما اضاف المقال ان واشنطن قلقه من
فقدان هيمنتها على العالم ولذلك اعدت على
ما يبدو خططا لضرب روسيا
روسيا تتحضر لضم غواصات نوويه جديده الى
اسطولها البحري مما يشكل تحديا دفاعيا
للولايات المتحده
مع الزميل صهيب جراير
المشاهدين مع الحديث الاوكراني عن تعزيزات
الروسيه في البحر الاسود تتحضر روسيا لضم
غواصات نوويه جديده الى اسطولها البحري
مما يشكل تحديا دفعيا للولايات المتحده
والنيتو وفقا يوزويك اكبر شركه لبناء
السفن في روسيا والمنتج الوحيد في البلاد
للغواصات التي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه
ستزود البحريه الروسيه اذا
بغواصتين جديدتين الامبراطور الكسندر
الثالث وكريسنو يارس هذه الغواصه اذا
الجديده كذلك في نهايه العام الجاري غواصه
الامبراطور الكسندر الثالث مشاهدينا حظيت
باهتمامي الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
شخصيا العام الماضي ورفع عليها العلم
الروسي في التاسع والعشرين من ديسمبر
الفائت هذه الغواصه النوويه مشاهدينا هي
قادره على حمل سته عشر صاروخا باليستيا
عابرا للقارات وهي سابع صواريخ من عائله
بوري اي ومن المقرر بدء التجارب البحريه
عليها في يونيو المقبل كجزء من برنامج
التسلح الحالي في روسيا لضمان امن البلاد
في السنوات القادمه وفقا لما اعلنه الرئيس
الروسي هذا فيما يتعلق بالغواصات الروسيه
اما على الجانب الاخر الجانب الامريكي
القوه البحريه الامريكيه المتمثله باسطول
اوهايو
لديها اربعه عشره غواصه مشاهدين ويشار
اليها باسم بومرز وكل غواصه نوويه من هذا
الاسطول تحمل ما يصل الى عشرين صاروخا
بالستيان برؤوس حربيه متعدده وموجهه بشكل
مستقل كما انها تمتلك ثلاثه فتحات ذات قطر
اكبر تسمح بالنقل السريع لمنصه الامداد
ووحدات استبدال المعدات ومكونات الالات
بما يسمح بوقت اقل عند التجديد والصيانه
مواقف جديده للخارجيه الصينيه بما يخص
موضوع التايوان حيث تعارض بشده بيع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ذخائر لي
تايوان وتطالب واشنطن بوقف التسليح
والتواصل العسكريه مع تايوان نتابع قالت
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا بربوك
ان اوكرانيا يجب ان تحدد بنفسها شروط
السلام مع روسيا ومنها قرار عوده القرم
الى روسيا مشيره الى ان برلين لن تقدم
نصائح لكياف في هذا الشان كما شددت ايضا
على استمرار دعم بلادها لاوكرانيا
رفض المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيليه
التي دعا فيها الى محو قريه حوار
الفلسطينيه واصفا اياها بغير المسؤوله
والمثيره للاشمئزاز والبغيضه حد التحريض
على العنف ودع برايس رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو وغيره من كبار
المسؤولين الى التنصر علنا من تصريحات
وزير الماليه
الشبكه المئات من المتظاهرين مع الشرطه
الاسرائيليه امام صالون لتصفيف الشعر وسط
تل ابيب قيل ان زوجه رئيس الوزراء ساره
نتنياهو كانت بداخله بعد يوم مضطرب احتاج
فيه ضد برنامج الاصلاح القضائي وحولت
العناصر الامنيه تفريق الحشود في محاوله
للسماح لساره نتنياهو بالمغادره وسط
شعارات تردد بحكومه نتنياهو مرددين عباره
تقول ان البلد يحترق وسارى تصفف شعرها كما
اعتقلت القوات 39 متظاهرا بسبب ما وصفته
باعمال شغب حيث اكد رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو ان الحق بالتظاهر ليس حقا بالفوضى
مخيم الهول في سوريا يتوقف الزمن مشاهد
العنف والتطرف التي رافقت تنظيم داعش في
المناطق التي كانت يوما خاضعه له تتكرر
هناك لكن الاخطر هذه الايام هو ما رصدته
العربيه خلال جولتها الحصريه جيل جديد
للتنظيم داخل المخيم الذي يسجل ولادات
شهريه لنساء داعش اللواتي يحملن دون
ازواجهن عبر استغلال المراهقين والذكور
المتعاطفين مع التنظيم لهذه الغايه
[موسيقى]
يشرح القائمون على اداره مخيم الهول خريطه
اقسامه قبل جوله الاستكشاف الوضع داخله
لكنهم يقولون انما نراه هنا غير كامل
واعداد قاطهم مخيم غير دقيقه فهناك حالات
زواج غير موثقه ومواليد جدد يتفاجئون
بوجودهم في خيم الاجنبيات كلما شنوا
عمليات مداهمه وهي خيم يفترض انها تضم
نساء الدواعش واطفالهن فقط فالازواج اما
في السجون او قتله تصريح مفاجئ بدا انه
يحتاج شرحا
لنفهم القصه توجهنا الى دلبرين كوباني
القياديه في وحده حمايه المراه في اقليم
الجزيره وهي كانت اشرفت على حمله
الانسانيه والامر التي شمتها القوات
الامنيه ضد خلايا داعش في الهول
يجب ان يكون قسم الاجنبيات في المخيم دون
رجال اثناء العمليه اكتشفنا انهم اخفوا
المراهقين الذكور في الانفاق التي حفروها
كانوا يفعلون ذلك حتى لا تتمكن قوات الامن
من اكتشافهم انهم يستخدمون هؤلاء
المراهقين لاغراض الانجاب
هناك لاجئون عراقيون وبعض النازحين
السوريين يذهبون خلصتا الى قسم الاجانب
للزواج من اجنبيات انهم يستخدمون كل هذه
الطرق لانجاب المزيد من الاطفال
تعتقد القوى الامنيه هنا انما يجري في
المخيم هو استغلال للاطفال والمراهقين
بقرار من التنظيم لذا تقول انها طلبت من
النساء في قسم الاجنبيات تسليم الاطفال
فوق السن الخامسه عشره لاخذهم الى مراكز
منفصله كما شنت عمليات لمنع تسلل رجال من
اقسام السوريين والعراقيين الى هذا القسم
لغرض الزواج من الاجنبيات
حاولنا الحصول على رد او تعليق نساء
الدواعش لكن دون جدوى
غادرنا قسم الاجنبيات واتجهنا لاقسام
السوريين والعراقيين وهي مخصصه لداعشيات
سوريات وعراقيات كما تضم نساء وازواجهن
نزحوا من مناطق السيطره داعش وهؤلاء يقول
المسؤولون عن الامن هنا انه يصعب الجزم
بعدم ارتباطهم بالتنظيم سابقا او بخلاياه
داخل المخيم حاليا
هذا ناصح سوري يروي بعض ما يجري داخل
المخيم
سمعت انه واحد يتجوز يعني اكثر من اربعه
ان الشروع يعني
سمعت انه
تزوجت لماذا في واحد معنا مطلوب وحربان
منهم
قائلين لزوجته تخلعيه
يعني
يجعل اعداد المواليد شهريا اكبر من
المتوقع
[موسيقى]
عدد الولادات هي كثيره جدا يعني بالشهر
بالشهر اللي فات كان عنا 61 حاله ولاده
باقسام العراقيين فقط
[موسيقى]
جيل جديد باعداد كبيره ينشا في خيم
الدواعش في الهول على الغالب يحاول
التنظيم بهذا ضمان استمراريته وتعقيد مهمه
محاربته صار بن عشوبان العربيه الحسكه
صاروخا على متنه طاقه محطه فضاء من ولايه
فلوريدا الامريكيه تم ارفاق اثنين مرواد
الفضاء التابعين لوكاله ناسا وراءت فضاء
روسيه ورائد فضاء اخر من الامارات العربيه
المتحده بالكبسوله الموجوده فوق الصاروخ
في رحله الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه التابعه
لناسا
بعد مقتل اكثر من 88 شخصا في اليونان
نتيجه التصادم قطارين نتيجه خطا بشري
واستقاله وزير النقل من الحكومه اشتبك
متظاهرون مع الشرطه في اثينا بعد تنظيم
مظاهره خارج مكاتب شركه قطار هلينك وبسبب
الاحتجاجات اطلقت الشرطه الغاز الموسيل
للدموع على المتظاهرين الذين رشقوا
الحجاره واشعلوا النيران في الشوارع
وننتقل لنشاهد هذه الصور المباشره لموقع
حادث التصادم حيث تحاول الفرق المتخصصه
انتشال حطام
القطاريين طبعا كان اصطدم قطار ركاب يقل
المئات بقطار شحن في مدينه لاريسا
ونشاهد الرافعات تستخدم لرفع الحطام اثناء
عمليه البحث
نهايه النشره تذكيرهم
البحريه الامريكيه تكشف عن مصادره شحنه
اسلحه ايرانيه غير شرعيه في الثالث
والعشرين من فبراير الماضي
ذخائر وامريكيه لتايوان لتعزيز قدراتها
الدفاعيه والصين تعلن عن معارضتها الشديد
شركه سبيس اكس تطلق صاروخا يحمل طاقم محطه
فضاء من ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه
اراكم على راس الساعه الى اللقاء